Kovach 19 spread around the world in  weeks and that leaves little or no time  to develop something new timely  intelligence around the global spread of  infectious diseases needs to come from  better routine diagnostics and active  surveillance early detection and  response are going to be the key to  prevent the next pandemic so I want to  wake up in a world I want to help build  the world that is essentially better  prepared that doesn't continues to take  calculated risks but in invest in the  solutions that are going to make an  impact this investment is an investment  in our people in our future in our  company and in our security it's time to  implement them now